Texas Republican congressman Mac
Thornberry is chair of the House Armed
Services Committee and he joins us
tonight from Capitol Hill mr. chairman I
want to pick up on the comment from
defense secretary mattis that he wants
to see international chemical weapons
inspectors come into Syria this weekend
does that indicate to you that there
will be no u.s. strike until those
inspectors are safely out of Syria well
I think it's important that we not say
when or how or where we may act clearly
if Assad allows these chemical
inspectors in we will be very cautious
about anything that could endanger them
but at the same time I don't think that
most people believe there's a high
likelihood is gonna let actual
inspectors in to prove what he has done
which is a terrible atrocity we can't
lose sight of that as we have mentioned
president Trump at least in his tweets
has been sending mixed messages
I forget about the time and I understand
your sensitivity about that are you
persuaded that he is eventually going to
order a military strike to deter or at
least under message of Bashar Assad I
know you convinced that's the right
answer well I'm convinced he has not yet
reached a decision on a military element
I believe they are looking at diplomatic
economic as well as military options you
know I do remember what happened a year
ago where there was a chemical attack
that killed close to a hundred people
there was a targeted strike against
those Syrian military units that had
used chemical weapons and in the process
about 17% of the Syrian Air Force was
destroyed I think while it did not stop
them from using chemical weapons it
slowed them down a little bit and so
part of what the international community
needs to think about is how to send a
message not go so far as to escalate but
also not do nothing which would I think
send the message that this is okay well
you say not ask
but there are a number of your
colleagues in Congress who are
suggesting if we're gonna take another
military strike that the US should
escalate in other words not the same
kind of attack as last time but
something more that indicates that in a
sense the Western community is upping
the ante if Bashar al-assad continues
with this kind of behavior do you agree
with that well I agree that that he
needs to pay a price
but I also believe the United States is
not going to fix all of the problems in
Syria and we do not want to get involved
in the Syrian civil war what we want to
do with our international partners is
say that it send a clear message if with
force if necessary and I would support
such an action that that this is beyond
the realm of human what humanity can
tolerate to kill innocent people with
these horrible weapons that were
outlawed nearly a hundred years ago
and and so I think we need to send a
clear message but obviously none of us
want to get into some sort of escalation
with Russia and others well I was going
to pick up exactly on that point which
is that the Russians have been talking
tough and yesterday they said that if we
did launch a military strike they would
not only try to shoot down our missiles
but might also respond to the ships the
US ships that have fired them do you
worry that this could turn into a
confrontation between the US and Russia
well I think it has to be carefully
calibrated and that's why I mentioned
the specific goal of last year of
military strikes against the Syrian
units that use these chemical weapons to
kill innocent people
carefully targeted not going after those
other installations where Russians may
be present but but being focused but at
the same time sending a clear message
and I think that's the kind of
appropriate response proportional
response that probably continues to make
sense
finally chairman last week the president
said that he wants to get out of Syria
soon and in fact he reportedly had to be
persuaded that he would keep us force
on the ground in Syria for six months
now he may be about to launch a military
strike against Syria which has raised
the question for a lot of people in fact
do we have a coherent strategy with how
to deal with the situation in Syria well
I think it's important to keep in mind
number one we're in Syria to fight Isis
and we have had tremendous success in
narrowing down the area that Isis
controls we have not eradicated them
however and what we want to make sure is
that we have finished the job
so that Isis 3.0 cannot reappear
remember the terrible mistake President
Obama made when he completely got out of
Iraq and Isis then came back and and we
had to go in with much higher costs in
all respects in order to get rid of them
we are not in Syria to fix all of the
political mess the civil war that
President Trump inherited but you have
this chemical weapons issue which again
as secretary mattis testified today is
really an issue for civilization that we
can't just turn away from so we need to
keep our interests in mind its terrorism
but also acknowledge that we have these
other targeted interests without trying
to go in and fix everything that's
broken there Chairman Mac Thornberry of
the House Armed Services Committee
chairman thanks so much for joining us
tonight thank you sir